Things are looking bright for one of Marvel
Comics' darkest characters.
While critics have used their reviews to tear
Venom limb from stretchy limb, the filmgoing
masses appear to really be growing attached
to the symbiotic superhero movie and they've
unexpectedly sent the film's audience approval
rating soaring on Rotten Tomatoes.
By the end of Venom's opening weekend, the
Sony Pictures production was sporting a surprisingly
stellar 89 percent audience approval score
on Rotten Tomatoes — a huge difference compared
to its much lower critical score on the site.
The audience rating is the result of more
than 16,000 votes, seeming to indicate that
quite a few filmgoers made a point of hitting
up Rotten Tomatoes after seeing the movie
to let their thoughts be known.
The apparently positive audience reaction
is obviously a huge turnaround from what reviewers
thought.
When Venom slithered its slimy body onto the
silver screen at the start of October, movie
critics weren't exactly loving what the symbiote
and its host had to offer.
The very first reports weren't terrible, but
they seemed split on how to feel about the
not-quite-a-superhero superhero flick.
Some found the relationship between Tom Hardy's
Eddie Brock and the alien Venom to be a highlight,
while others found joy in the movie's humor,
whether it was intentional or not.
But the inconsistent tone of the movie, along
with its failure to follow through on some
of its more interesting elements, were major
points of contention in these first impressions.
Once Sony Pictures lifted its review embargo,
the floodgates opened, and critics took their
knives out on Venom.
Some argued the movie was so bad it's good,
while others contended that the whole thing
was just plain bad.
"Like a turd...in the wind."
And since its theatrical release, Venom has
sputtered to a paltry 31 percent critical
approval rating on Rotten Tomatoes, which
would seem to mark the Ruben Fleischer-directed
movie as a certified stinker.
Richard Roeper with the Chicago Sun-Times
slammed the movie as "a tone-deaf, uneven,
and maddeningly dumb clunker that never settles
on an identity."
Another critic venomously described the production
as "a chaotic, unfocused, assembly edit of
a movie, that appears to have had all the
vitality and humanity parasitically sucked
out of it."
Yikes.
Though critics and general audiences don't
always come to the same conclusion regarding
the quality of a film, Venom appears to be
a particularly unique case, as there's a significant
difference between the way professional reviewers
and casual moviegoers are reacting to the
movie.
If you go by the numbers, from the high audience
score to the record-setting opening weekend,
it seems like audiences are straight-up loving
this movie.
Venom is hardly the first movie that critics
and audiences have clashed over like this.
In 2017, only 40 percent of professional reviewers
gave the Justice League movie a positive rating,
while 74 percent of the audience voters claimed
to have enjoyed it.
A similar sequence of events played out in
2016 with Suicide Squad.
The critical score for the supervillain team-up
flick came in at 28 percent.
But once audiences saw it for themselves,
60 percent of Rotten Tomatoes voters gave
it a positive rating.
Are the critics wrong?
Or are some audiences just that easy to please?
It's hard to say for certain.
Perhaps the most infamous recent example of
critics and fans fiercely disagreeing about
a movie's merits came in December 2017 with
Star Wars: The Last Jedi.
But in that instance, the situation was flipped,
with 91 percent of reviewers loving writer-director
Rian Johnson's entry in the franchise.
Fans of the series, however, seemed to largely
revolt against this sentiment, with only 45
percent of users saying they enjoyed it.
So it just goes to show: this is a phenomenon
that goes both ways.
Venom's opening weekend brought in over $205
million worldwide.
Coupled with the sky-high audience score,
the people in charge at Sony will likely be
encouraged to press on with plans to turn
Venom into the start of a full-fledged cinematic
universe, using the movie as a springboard
to launch other stories from Sony's spider-focused
stable of Marvel Characters.
With this kind of reception, we're almost
definitely getting a Venom 2.
Hopefully that one can thread the needle a
little better, and serve up something critics
and audiences both love.